اهلا بكم الى ساعه جديده من تغطيتنا لحرب
السلطه او الجنرالين كما باتت توصف في
السودان والتي شارف يومها الخامس على
الانتهاء وفيما الاشتباكات تتواصل تتزايد
المخاوف من توسع رقعه النزاع ليدق اسوار
الدول المجاوره ويزعزع امنها
[موسيقى]
حرب الازقه والشوارع معديه وقد تتسرب شيئا
فشيئا لحاره مجاوره واخره لها طالما ان
الجنراللين سقطا بمحظور الاقتتال الداخلي
فخ اوقع بدول محيطه منذ سنوات انها
اقتصادها وافقر شعوبها
السودان لحق بالركب ولم يفته القطار دوله
شلها غياب المركزيه السياسيه والعسكريه
كما جيرانها ليبيا وسوريا ولبنان حيث
يفترض انها دول مستقله تتمتع بالسياده وحق
تقرير المصير اي دول ديجوري وفق القانون
الدولي لكنها وجدت نفسها على الجانب الاخر
من القائمه دول مسلوبه القرار ومهمشه بحكم
الواقع او ديفاكتو
هذه الفوضى الداخليه مرميه على حافه
التوسع بحكم موقع السودان الجيو السياسي
بالغ الاهميه فالوضع السوداني يهدد بنشر
الفوضى في دول مجاوره وعيسى في بعضها فساد
بالاصل ارتريا واثيوبيا من الشرق تشاد
وليبيا من الغرب وصولا الى مصر من الجهه
الشماليه فمن شان اي اضطراب في السودان ان
يزعزع امنها القومي ويضر بحصصها المائيه
مع سعي اثيوبيا لتعبئه سد النهضه السودان
يطل كذلك على البحر الاحمر الذي يربط اهم
ممرين بحريين هما باب المندب وقناه السويس
ما يزيد مغريات الدوله الذهبيه الكثيره في
عيون دول كبرى بينها روسيا وتركيا فحلم
القاعده البحريه هناك تتشاركه الدولتان
حرب الجنرالين تمتلك الخلطه الناجحه
والسريعه للحرب الاهليه للاشتباكات طويله
الامد وتوزعها على مساحات واسعه وامكانيه
انزلاق الحركات المسلحه الاخرى الى المشهد
اما الحل السياسي المامول فبايد ليست
متوفره حاليا بل ممدوده الى اوكرانيا
وتايوان حل لن يكون مغيرا عن سابقه
الخجوله قبل اندلاع حرب اللا منتصر اي
خساره الطرفين وانتقال القياده لطرف ثالث
خمسه ايام دمويه عاشها السودان والافق لا
يزال مسدودا امام الحرب بين القوتين
العسكريتين
الممسكتين بزمام البلاد الاشتباكات تحولت
الى حرب مدن مفتوحه وفيما الحسم
رهن بالايام المقبله يواصل الطرفان
عملياتهما الجيش اعلن عن استعاده مطار
مروي وسلاح المهندسين ومنشات حول مقر
القياده العامه للقوات المسلحه في الخرطوم
حيث ما تزال قوات الدعم موجوده هناك قوات
حمايه فشلت بتحييد القواعد الجويه
والمطارات الاساسيه في البلاد خلافا
لخطتها الاساسيه فبعد اقتحامها لمطار مروي
شمال السودان واعلانها السيطره عليه عاد
الاخير لقبضه الجيش السوداني واقتصرت
مكاسبها جويا على قاعده جبل اولياء جنوب
العاصمه اضافه الى مطاري في دارفور هما
مطار الفاشر شمالا ومطار صبيره الدولي
غربا فشل قوات الدعم السريع بالسيطره على
كافه القواعد الجويه مكن الجيش من استخدام
مقاتلاته لاستهداف تمركزات وسيارات الدعم
السريع بالعاصمه تحديدا وهي اليات غير
مدرعه وهي سهله التدبير كما ما هذا
استخدام سلاح الجو الطريق امام الجيش
للسيطره على مقرات رئيسيه لقوات الدعم
السريع في محيط العاصمه
كمعسكرات سوبا جنوب خرطوم في الطيبه
والطيبه في شمالها والصالحه ايضا وكرري في
ام درمان كما نشاهد وضمنت كذلك عدم تمكن
الدعم السريع من الحفاظ على مقراتها التي
تحتوي على احتياطيات لوجستيا في ولايتي
النيل الازرق والنيل الابيض وبورسودان
والقضارف وكسلا اما نجاحات قوات الدعم
السري ع فتتمثل بقطع التواصل بين شمال
العاصمه وايضا جنوبها من خلال سيطرتها على
الجسور وتعطيل حركه المرور
اساليب القتال تختلف ووسائله تتعدد
في السودان كما في اي منطقه توتر كل شيء
مباح لهزم الطرف الاخر
قناصه متخفون استهدفوا العميد عبد العظيم
احمد بالقرب من سلاح الاشاره بالعاصمه
الخرطوم
خلال تشييع جنازته تحلق حوله ابنائه
وزوجته مودعين اياه الى مثواه الاخير قبيل
ايام قليله فقط من عيد الفطر
[موسيقى]
هو الالتزام موجود لكنه جزئي او نقول هو
التزام بالنسبه لكل الهدمات السابقه التي
كانت في الايام السابقه اليوم شاهدنا اقل
حده فقط استمعنا الى طلقات الرصاص ومضادات
للطائرات مرتين او ثلاث مرات فقط منذ
بدايه هذه الهدنه فهي تعتبر افضل الهدنه
حتى الان
منذ بدات هذه الهدنه وهي الهدنه الرابعه
كذلك كانت هناك خدمتين لثلاثه او اربع
ساعات وكانت خدمه 24 ساعه بالامس وهذه هي
الهدنه الثانيه في 24 ساعه كذلك
ابتدات في السادسه من مساء اليوم منذ
السادسه استمعنا الى دوله القصاص كذلك
مضادات للطائرات لكنها محدوده وفي مناطق
كذلك محدوده لكنها موجوده وهي الاقل حده
حتى الان منذ بدايه هذه الاشتباه هل ام
كنك التاكد من اين خرجت هذه الاصوات يعني
من مناطق حول القياده العامه مثلا او
القصر
نعم هي من ذات المناطق التي ظلت تتكرر
فيها الاشتباكات في محيط القياده العامه
كذلك هنا في منطقه بحري في جهه كافولي راح
كابولي في مربع سته بالتحديد اجتمعنا الى
مضاد للطائرات عقيمه الافطار ايضا سمعنا
الى اطلاق رصاصات كذلك متفرقه في ام درمان
بشكل عام لا ندري اي منطقه في ام درمان
بالضبط
سالم اود ان اسال عن نزوح الالاف يعني
اليوم الوكاله الفرنسيه تحدثت عن النزوح
الالاف من السكان بالخرطوم الى مناطق اخرى
من السودان
نعم هذا النزوح نستطيع ان نقول انه جزئي
ليس كلي يعني ليس بالحجم الذي نستطيع ان
نسميه ذلك النزوح الكامل هناك من سكان ما
زالوا موجودين في الخرطوم ليس نزوحا كاملا
هو نزوح جزئي وغالبيه هذا النطوح هو لاناس
اهلهم اصلا في اقاليم السودان وكانوا هنا
يعملون يعني من العمال باشكالهم تجاره
كذلك جزء من التجار الذين يعملون في السوق
كذلك
ممن يعملون في التجاره بشكل عام في
الاسواق حتى من يعملون في المحل التجاريه
كذلك لهم اهل في الاقاليم نسبه قليله من
الذين خرجوا من الخرطوم وليس لهم اهل في
الاقاليم هذه نسبه قليله جدا جدا ان لم
تكن غير موجوده في الغالب هو مناسب لديهم
اهلهم في الاقاليم خرجوا
باسباب كثيره اما ان العمل نفسه توقفت
كمنطقي جدا ان يذهبوا الى اهلهم لان مغلقه
والشوارع مغلقه المحله التجاريه مغلقه
كذلك
الحركه تبدو غير موجوده في الشوارع واما
ان يكون اصلا لديهم اهل هناك فذهبوا
ليبتعدوا عن هذه الازمه وتبعاتها وان
يبتعد عن القلق والتوتر الموجود في الايام
الماضيه بسبب الاعير النائيه مضادات
الطائرات
الاشتباكات المدويه كذلك الدانات التي تقع
على البيوت وكذلك الشظايا من المخلوقات
كذلك كل هذه الامور تجعلهم يبتعدون قليلا
عن هذه الازمه وطبيعتها سالم بما انه
تتحدث عن التزام جزئي بالهدنه هو افضل من
الهدن الهدن السابقه فعليا ما مدى استفاده
مؤسسات انسانيه من هذه الهدنه او حتى يمكن
لتزويد الناس بالمواد الغذائيه ايضا
المستشفيات بما ينقصها
هل رصدتم استفاده من ذلك
نعم هو تحدي لان الهدنه ما زالت في
بدايتها لنقل انه تحدي ينتظر هذه المنظمات
باشكالها
والمؤسسات المعنيه بهذا الامر وزاره الصحه
الاتحاديه كانت كانت قد اطلقت مجموعه من
النداءات في موضوع القطاع الصحي ربما هذه
فرصه لوزاره الصحه
لتطبيق جزء من الخطط التي هي تبحث عن
ايصال فيها المساعدات وايصال كذلك الدعم
اللوجسي للمستشفيات لاصلاح ما يمكن اصلاحه
في المستشفيات من ايصال الكوادر الطبيه
لها الكوادر الطبيه الكافيه المعينات
الكافيه كذلك لعمل هذه المستشفيات هي فرصه
ايضا للرجال الاحياء وهي الان تبحث في
ايصال ايضا مجموعه يعني تعين في بعض
الامور المتعلقه بالمياه والامداد المائي
كذلك المتعلقه بالكهرباء وايصال الكهرباء
واصلاح الاعطال الموجوده في الكهرباء كل
هذه هي تح كل هذه المنظمات والمنظومات
كلها تحدي ايضا لولايه الخرطوم التي كانت
قد وعدت باصلاح محطاتها المياه وكذلك وعدت
بارجاع التيار الكهربائي كاملا بالتنسيق
مع الشركه السودانيه للكهرباء لتوزيع
الكهرباء كل هذه الامور
هي تحدي امام كل هذه الجهات الان عليها ان
تبدا وتنسق والهدنه الان في بدايتها ما
زال هناك وقت كافي لانجاز بعض الامور ايضا
فرصه
للنزوح عفوا للاجئين او المحتجزين عفوا
المحتجزين في الاماكن ان يتم الان بحث طرق
لاجلائهم من اماكن الاحتجاز وايصالهم الى
اهلهم وذويهم هناك ايضا مسؤوليه تقع على
الجيش السوداني في مساله الجسور ان هنالك
اناس في مدن مختلفه وانقطعت بهم الصبوله
الان بسبب هذه الازمه نريد ان يصلوا
الجسور من يسيطر على الجسور التي تربط بين
العاصمه الخرطوم وباقي المدن الان
[تصفيق]
هدنه هشه لا اثر لها على الارض
فاصوات اطلاق النيران ودوي الانفجارات
سمعت باستمرار في مناطق مختلفه من الخرطوم
وتحديدا حول مقر الجيش والقصر الجمهوري
سلسله الادانات بمسؤوليه خلقها لا زالت
متبادله ليقذف كل منهم كره الاتهام في
ملعب الاخر رغم الجهود الامميه والدوليه
المكثفه
الطرفان المتقاتلان لا يعطيان الانطباع
بانهما يريدان وساطه من اجل السلام بينهما
على الفور ما كنت افعله في اليومين
الماضيين هو محاوله التوسط في توقف انساني
لمده ثلاث ساعات في اليوم
الجيش السوداني فمسؤوليه عن الهدنه الهشه
واكد في بيان له ان قوات الدعم السريع لم
تلتزم بها وهاجمت على مواقع استراتيجيه من
محيط المطار ومبنى القياده العامه السيطره
على هذه المواقع تعد انتصارا كبيرا قد
يحسم بقيه المعارك في المواقع الاخرى وفقا
لخبراء
وبسبب اهميته القصوى حصن الجيش مركز
القياده من الجهتين الشماليه والغربيه لكن
المعارك اشتدت في الجهتين الجنوبيه
والشرقيه المقابلتين لمطار الخرطوم
قوات الدعم السريع وجهت بدورها ايضا
اتهامات مماثله لقوات الجيش بمخالفه
للقانون الدولي الانساني وقواعد الاشتباك
وخرق الهدنه المتفق عليها ببساطه دوليه
وتبقى الاتهامات متبادله وسط تضارب كبير
في الروايات بين الجانبين العربيه
[موسيقى]
ومن جنوب الخرطوم ينضم الينا الصحه في
مدثر محمد احمد اهلا بك السيد مدثر يعني
هذه الهدنه التي يعني الالتزام بها جزئي
لانه سمعت
اطلاق نار متفرق في العاصمه كيف يمكن
وصفها وهل تعول على الالتزام الكامل بها
بالساعه القادمه
منذ دخولها هنا في منطقه جنوب الخرطوم
هناك التزام كان بهذه الهدنه منذ دخول
ساعه الهدنه كانت منطقه جنوب الخرطوم في
منطقه ما يعرف بارض المعسكرات صوب المعسكر
يتبع لقوات الدعم السريع شهد اشتباكات
عنيفه
لحوالي ساعه قبل قبل دخول الهدنه حيز
التنفيذ ولكن مع دخول الهدنه حيث توقفت
الاشتباكات تماما
شوهدت اعمده الدخان لفتره طويله في منطقه
جنوب الخرطوم جراء تلك الاشتباكات منذ
دخول الهدنه لم نستمع الى اي اشتباكات او
اصوات اشتباك في هذه المنطقه منطقه جنوب
الخرطوم في منطقه سوبا منطقه جنوب الحزام
منطقه شرق النيل في منطقه سوبا شرق لا
توجد بها اي اصوات لاشتباكات يبدو ان هناك
التزام من
حتى الان لهذه الهدنه هنا في منطقه جنوب
الخرطوم منطقه جنوب الخرطوم منذ منذ صباح
اليوم شهدت مساله
بعدد كبير جدا من الاسر التي تتجه صوب
الولايات التي تقع جنوبها الخرطوم منطقه
الولايات الجزيره وولايه العميل الولايات
التي تقع جنوب الخرطوم كانت هناك حركه
لخروج العائلات التي كما ذكر الزميل سالم
هي حركه
يعني ليست بالنزوح وانما هي تاتي تزامنا
مع عطله العيد عيد الفطر المبارك هذه
المنطقه تشهد مساله عوده الاسر الى
اهاليهم في الولايات
يعني خمسه
ايام عاشها السودان
وعاشها جنوب الخرطوم كيف يمكن وصفها كيف
كانت حده المعارك اين هي الجبهات التي
كانت اكثر سخونه بجنوب الخرطوم
نعم منطقه جنوب الخرطوم شهدت خلال خمسه
ايام اشتباكات في اليوم الثالث منذ امس
الاول في منطقه جبره شهيده اشتباكات حديثه
جدا منطقه
بدات هذه الاشتباكات منذ اليوم السبت بدات
في منطقه جنوب الخرطوم هنا في منطقه ارض
المعسكرات صوبا حيث المعسكر
معسكر ارض المعسكرات حيث به معسكر للدعم
السريع وهو الذي انطلقت منهم اصلا
الاحداث في ارض المعسكرات في سوبا
وبعد ذلك
شهدت اشتباكات هنا في منطقه سوبر شرق حيث
كانت هناك عدد من القوات الدعم السريه قد
تمركزت خلال اليومين الماضيين تم
التعامل معها بسلاح الجو خلال اليومين
الماضيين وكانت اشتراكات عنيفه جدا خلال
يومين الماضيين بخلاف هذه الاشتباكات في
منطقه جنوب الخرطوم شهدت كذلك منطقه
بعض المحطات منطقه محطه جبل اولياء عدد
الى الضخ كذلك محطات التي كانت في مناطق
بوري عادت الى الضخ
عدد عوده تدريجيه الى الاحياء في منطقه
جنوب الخرطوم كذلك التي يركض استقرار خلال
يوم امس واليوم في خلال ثلاثه ايام
الماضيه كان هناك شكاوى عديده من
المواطنين هي في منطقه جنوب الخرطوم من
انقطاع تيار الكهربائي وكذلك انقطاع
المياه شهدت هناك يعني صفوف ونداءات
انسانيه عديده لعمدهم بالمياه هناك عدد من
التناكر كانت قد
وصلت الى هذه المناطق لتزويد المواطنين
بالمياه ولكن تدريجيا منذ غده الامس
تمكنت الاتيان بحسب ما علمته الولايات
الخرطوم من اعاده المحطات التي كانت قد
توقفت
عن عن العمل بفعل انقطاع خلال الايام
قبل دخول هذه الهدنه
الساعات التنفيذ كان هناك معلومات عن حاله
تحشيد للطرفين هل رصدتم ذلك بجنوب الخرطوم
في جنوب الخرطوم هنا التحشيد الذي يعني
رصدناه ما يتم التحدث عن الدخول العدد من
القوات الدعم السريع في منطقه
الشرق النيل هي قوات كان قد تحدثت عنها
المصادر انها قدمت من
الولايات الشرقيه بمنطقه البطانه
وتمركزت في عدد من المناطق هنا في منطقه
وفي شرق النيل في منطقه
العلفون وكانت هذه المناطق قد شهدت
اشتباكات عنيفه بالامس
لذلك التحسين الذي تم
خلال هجمه الامس التي لم تكن
لم يتم فيها الالتزام الكامل بتلك الهدنه
لكن اليوم لم نسمع عن اي تحشيش هنا في هذه
المنطقه في منطقه جنوب الخرطوم كانت هناك
بعض التحركات
بالاضافه للجسور التي ذكرها الزميل الفعلي
جسر الذي يربط صوبه غربي في صوبا شرق ايضا
يسيطر عليه او يتواجد فيه مجموعه من قوات
الدعم السريع الذين سافروا او الذين خرجوا
من ولايه الخرطوم بهذا اليوم تحدثوا عن ان
هناك ارتكازات
جنود الدعم السريع ولكن لم تكن هناك اي
يعني اشتباكات بينهم وبين المواطنين او
بينه وبين القوات المسلحه هل ترى سيد مظفر
بانه بامكان القوى المدنيه القيام بدور
وساطه هل ذلك ممكن بهذه الاوقات
قبل ان اسمع رايك سيد مدثر دعنا نشاهد هذا
الفيديو
لسيطرت قوات الجيش على اموال
لقوات الدعم السريع نستمع
[موسيقى]
اذا شاهدنا هذا الفيديو للجيش السوداني
يظهر حيازته لاموال تابعه للدعم السريع
اعود اليك سيد مدثر كنت سالتك عن امكانيه
ان يكون للقوى المدنيه
دور وساطه
نعم اقول مدنيه التي وقعت على الاتفاق
الايطالي كانت قد تحدثت بالامس في بيان عن
اجتماع عقدته
لبحث الاوضاع التي تحدث الان وتجد الان
للسودان تحدثت هذه القوه المدنيه عن ضروره
وقف اطلاق النار في المقام الاول ومن ثم
الدخول الى عمليه الحوار او العوده مجددا
الى الحوار تحدثت عن انه في البدايه لابد
من وقف هذه الحرب وقف اطلاق النار ومن ثم
العوده
لعمليه الحوار مجددا وفقا لاتفاق الاطاري
الذي تم التوقيع عليه في الخامس بين القوى
المدنيه والمكونه العسكري ولكن بما يعني
يؤلمه الطرفين الان المتحاربين لا يوجد اي
طرف قد ابدا استعداده لمساله الحوار حتى
الان في هذه حتى هذه اللحظه شكرا جزيلا لك
من جنوب الخرطوم الصحفي مدثر محمد احمد
من بين قتلى الاشتباكات في السودان بين
الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع صيدلي سوداني
اشتهر بمشاركته الفاعله فاحتجاجات ديسمبر
2018 حيث قضى بعد ان سقطت قذيفه في مكان
اقامته
تيجاني مسلتي كان احد ابرز جنود احتجاجات
ديسمبر قاد المظاهرات التي اندلعت في
السودان اواخر العام 2018 قدم خدمات
علاجيه للمحتاجين وشارك في العديد من
الانشطه الميدانيه والاغاثيه لم يكن يعلم
انه سيكون ضحيه الاشتباكه الجاريه في
السودان قتل بعد ان سقطت عليه قذيفه في
مكان اقامته جراء الاقتتال الدائر بين
الجيش والدعم السريع نعاه زملائه في العمل
الطوعي ووصفوه باحد الجنود المجهولين
لثوره ديسم
[موسيقى]
منوهه مشاهدينا الى الاخبار العاجله نقلا
عن الجيش السوداني الذي يعني يقول بان
المسلحين الذين لجاوا لاتشاد يتبعون لقوات
الدعم السريع وبان قواتنا تتواجد في
مواقعها على حدود تشاد ولا مناوشات هناك
وكانت رويترز منذ قرابه الساعه نقلت عن
وزير الدفاع التشادي قوله بانه تم ايقاف
ونزع سلاح وحده سودانيه دخلت الى البلاد
قوامها 320 جنديا وحسب ما يؤكد الجيش
السوداني الان بانها تابعه للدعم السريع
ينضم الينا من الخرطوم اللواء الدكتور
امين اسماعيل مجذوب الخبير الامني
والاستراتيجيه في مركز الدراسات الدوليه
اهلا بك الدكتور امين يعني اذا نظرنا من
الناحيه العسكريه الى نمط المعارك بين
الطرفين نلاحظ بانه الاشتباكات متقطعه لا
طرف قادر على الحسم باي معركه او حتى
الحفاظ على نقطه يستولي عليها كيف يعني
ترى هذا النمط بالقتال وماذا ان استمر
هكذا
مساء الخير يا مرحب بك ومرحب المشاهدين
حقيقه الطرف الذي يريد ان يستولى هو الدعم
السريع
القوات المسلحه في مواقعها في قيادتها في
مطاراتها في مستودعاتها هي لا تريد ان
تسيطر على نقطه هي مسيطره على اماكننا
المعتدي هو الان الدعم السريع الذي يحاول
الاداء على هذه المواقع العسكريه
والسياديه ايضا هي قتال مدن غتال المدن
بيكون في مناوشات هو بيكون فيه كروه فر
وخروج الى المناطق السكنيه ثم العوده مره
اخرى وهذا ما يحدث في وسط الخرطوم وهذا
الدعم السريع فقدت
الامداد فقدت الاتصال بقياداتها واضح انه
في معاناه لذلك هي تتحرك بمركبات قليله
الان تم تحرير الاسر الرئاسي مطار الخرطوم
مطار مرعي
العديد من المواقف في الولايات حتى الان
في الخبر الذي ورد في العاجل ان هو من
الدعم السريع دخلت الى تشاد فهذا يعني ان
ان الان في مرحله المطارده والمتابعه
طبعا لانه هو تدخل الى اي هدف سواء انها
تريد ان تخرج من المعارض لانه المنطقه
اللي دخلت فيها تدفع لولايه غربي دارفور
وهنالك شمال دارفور وكل مناطق تؤدي الى
المناطق الحسيه الحدوديه
معموما نرجع الى الخرطوم بدات رواد الدعم
السريع انها تحاول الخروج تحاول طلب
امدادات وفي محاولات للتخريب اسواق تم
حرقها اعتداء على المواطنين
اعتداء على على بنايات اي بنايه موجوده
يتم اطلاق صواريخ عليها وحرقها ثم تتجه
القوات الى الخارج في في في نص هذه او في
وسط هذه الازمه برزه يعني الضوء في اخر
النفق وهو تسليم الجنود المصريين
تم تسليم الجنود المصريين بتنسيق مع
القياده السودانيه
وهؤلاء الجنود كانوا محجوزين قوات الدعم
السريع تم تسليم الى
ان اعود الى نقطه يعني تسرب او هروب حسب
ما وصفته بعض جنود قوات الدعم السريع الى
حدود تشاد هناك مخاوف حقيقيه من توسع رقعه
النزاع يعني
لينتقل الى دول المجاوره الجيش السوداني
حتى الان يقول لا مناوشات على الحدود مع
تشاد هل تتوقع ان تتغير الوضع ويصبح اكثر
سوءا
طبعا تداخلات غبليه
في منطقه دارفور وفي الدول المجاوره
الدعم السعوديه
وعلى اساس عشائري لذلك اذا كانت هنالك في
المستقبل
الغريب البعيد اذا كان هنالك دعومات ستصل
ستكون هنالك ازمه متحركه في دارفور ايضا
دور الجوار اصلا فيها ازمات متواجده عندنا
اربع دول الغربي هي ازمات
وحدات متفلته
قوات موجوده
لمن يدفع هذه الامور اذا اذا عملنا لها
مغاربه مع ما يحدث السودان ستجد نفسها
تدخل الى السودان للمشاركه في هذه الازمه
اذا وصلت الازمه الى حدود دارفور حاليا
الجميع يعمل على تبصير العاصمه ومن ثم لا
بد من الجلوس الغريمين لابد ان يجلسوا مع
بعض قبل الجلوس على طاوله واحده دكتور
امين كيف تفسر تعاظم قوه
الدعم السريع من حيث السلاح والعتاد
والقدره على مواجهه جيش وطني كالجيش
السوداني كيف تعاظم دورها خلال السنوات
الماضيه
هذه القوات انشئت بواسطه القوات المسلحه
بواسطه الجيش السوداني يعني انشات في نظام
السابق وتم تسليحها والتدريبها والطرق
عليها من ميزانيه الجيش السوداني وهذا امر
حدث النظام السابق واستمر يعني في صله
اربع سنوات الماضيه بالفتره الانتقاليه
ولذلك هي لديها امكانيات لانه الجيش
السوداني هو الذي اعطاه هذه الامكانيات
لان لا تعمل على اسناده
وبعد ان تتولى غايه الدعم السريع مسؤوليه
السياسيه انفتحت امام الابواب هذه
الزيارات علاقات خارجيه
وعلاقات دوليه
والحصول على بعض
التقنيات
التسليحيه والاجهزه الفنيه وهذه الامور
كانت على مراه او متسمع من الجيش فلذلك
لديه بامكانيات لكن كونه يتمرد او ينقلب
على الجيش السوداني هذا امر اخر وهو
المواجهه انه رفض الاندماج في الجيش
السوداني الاندماج هو جزء من المحافظه على
وحده القوات العسكريه الموجوده في السودان
نحن قلنا مقبلين على انتقال الديمقراطي
وفتره انتخابات لابد ان يكون جيش موحد
وليس عده جيوش موجوده
كيف تفس
ر القوات الدعم السريع
الاخيره والاشتباكات يعني وكانه الملاحظ
بانها لا تستطيع ان تتمركز وتسيطر انما
تتقصد ربما استنزاف الجيش ويعني بعث رسائل
باننا موجودون نستطيع ان نقاتل
اتفق معك تماما هذه استراتيجيه تسمى
استراتيجيه
وانهاك وطبعا هي اصلا
تدريبه على القتال في المناطق الصحراويه
هي انشات في دارفور الحركات المسلحه حينها
في العام 2013 لكن قتال المدن جديد عليها
هي جائزه الخرطوم بطلب من الرئيس السابق
بعد ثوره ديسمبر ثم تولد حراسه بعض
المواقع لكن قتال المدن والتمركز
بالنقاط فالقتال من شارع الى شارع ومن بيت
الى بيت هذه فنيات فلم لم تتدرب عليها
لذلك هي الان فعلا تحدث العالم والبيانات
باننا موجودون القوات المسلحه
انت لهذه الاستراتيجيه لديها استراتيجيه
تغيرها احيانا الوجود المدنيين
وتغيدها احيانا المحافظه على البنيات
التحتيه لذلك تستخدم اقل هو ممكنه وتعمل
بتركيز وتعمل على حصاره او استنزاف وتدعم
السريع حتى تفقد المؤن وتبغض
الاحتياجات اللوجستيه مواد تبغين القتال
والان هذا ما يحدث لهذه المرحله الان بعد
خمسه ايام هذه المجموعات تتفرغ عن الاحياء
واحيانا يطلبون من المواطنين
امدادهم بمواد غذائيه في بعض المناطق
تركوا المركبات وذهبوا بارجلين هذا امر
متوقع طبعا
جيش لديه مستودعات ولديه مصانع ولدي
الامداد دكتور
خطوط داده يعني متواصله لذلك انا اعتقد
انه نحن مخبرين
ساعه حاسمه ان شاء الله
وهذا الدعم السريع ايضا يجب ان تدرك ان
اذا استمرت هذا الامر ربما يعني تصل الى
مرحله
الحريق
او فقدان كل الامكانياته اذا كانت فيها
اصلا تابعه
القوات المسلحه لماذا هذا العناد في
القتال ولماذا لهذا العناد لتحدي القوات
المسلحه هذه امور
شخصيه انا في تقدير امور شخصيه وامور
مبنيه على خلاف سياسي يجب ان ينتهي سياسي
ليست هنالك فرصه
لنفقد جانب لانه كله سودانيون هذه الاسلحه
هذه الامكانيات هذه البنيات التحتيه كلها
لا يوجد مبرر للسيارات الصفريه وسنحصل على
نتائج عدميه لانه في النهايه لا تحصل على
اي نتيجه انت تريد ان تحكم دوله
محروقه دوله بدون بنيات تحتيه دوله بدون
تبني الدوله دي وتحكمه تحتاج الى 30 سنه
اخرى فيجب ان يفهم الجميع انه لا بديل
للتفاوض الا التفاوض الان والوصول الى حقن
الدماء والحفاظ على الشعب السوداني شكرا
جزيلا لك من الخرطومه لواء الدكتور امين
اسماعيل المجذوب الخبير الامني
والاستراتيجي في مركز الدراسات الدوليه
وسط القذائف والقصف المستمر منذ خمسه ايام
تتفجر الازمات الانسانيه بالسودان واحده
تلو الاخرى
بعد غروب الشمس تتناول هذه الاسره
السودانيه الفاتوره في لحظه صمت تنقطع فيه
اصوات المدافع ويرتفع صوت الاذان في
استراحه قصيره من الاشتباكات بين الجيش
وقوات الدعم السليم
الضائقه الاقتصاديه التي يعيشها السودان
منذ سنوات يسعى المواطنون لتجاهلها ولو
مؤقتا على مائده الافطار حيث باتت واقعا
يؤرقهم لا يمكنهم توقع تبعاته في ظل
القتال المحتدم
وبالرغم من انهم ربما تجاهلوا بشكل مؤقت
مشاكلهم الاقتصاديه الا نسمات الغذاء التي
تلوح في الافق اصبحت حقيقه واقعه في
السودان استمرار القتال تسبب في تفاقم
الوضع الانساني المتازم بالفعل 15 مليون
شخص بالكاد تتوفر لديهم مستلزمات الغذاء
الاساسيه بحسب تقرير للامم المتحده تقارير
اخرى تشير الى ان نحو اربعه ملايين طفل
دون الخامسه يعانون من بوادر سوء التغذيه
المعارك الدائره حاليا الحقت اضرارا
مباشره في البنيه التحتيه عائلات بالكامل
استبدلت المشروبات الرمضانيه بالمياه
بعدما استهدفت محطات المياه في بعض
الاحياء مثل بحر شمالي الخرطوم
عائلات اخرى لجات الى الاكتفاء بوجبه
واحده فقط في اليوم في سبيل التعايش مع
الظروف الصعبه
الاحياء الاوفر حظا يقتنص سكانها فرصه
هدوء الاشتباكات ليهرعوا الى محلات
البقاله ليجدوا ارففها فارغه تماما خاصه
التي تحتوي على المياه المعدنيه
اغلب الاحتياجات نقدر نجيبه بالنسبه
لاغلاق الطعم لسوبر ماركت والدكاكين
السيناريو الاكثر سوءا الذي لم يتوقعه
السودانيون كان اعلان برنامج الغذاء
العالمي وقفه مساعداته للبلاد على وقع
مقتل ثلاثه من موظفيه نتيجه الاشتباكات
بين قوات الدعم السريع والجيش
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الله
[موسيقى]
اظهرت صور جديده اشتعال النيران في صلاه
مطار الخرطوم جراء الاقتتال بين الجيش
السوداني وقوه الدعم السوداني
[موسيقى]
انضم الينا من الخرطوم وليد احمد النور
الصحفي والمحلل السياسي اهلا بك سيد وليد
يعني هل يمكن البناء على هذه الهدنه
الساريه الان لتتحول لوقف مؤقت ربما او
نهائي لاطلاق النار بين الطرفين
المتنازعين
مرحبا بك ومرحبا
بمشاهدي قناه العربيه الهدنه اذا تمت حتى
غدا في سادسه مساء ولم يتم خرقها كما فرغت
الهدنه الاولى يمكن ان تحقق تطور
طفيف يمكن اضافته يمكن ان يكون افضل
ويتطور الى وقف اضافي لاطلاق النار العدل
الاوضاع في السودان حاليا وصلت الى مرحله
مزريه جدا خاصه في الخرطوم المناطق
المحيطه بقياده الجيش
وبالاحياء
وبخاصه الجمهوري وبعض المناطق التي
يعيش سكانها في الاعدام للمياه وانعدام
للكهرباء
بعض الاسر التي وجدت
الطرق ان تغادر الولايات الخرطوم بردا الى
المدن القريبه
فلذلك يمكن اذا نجحت الغده حتى الان حسب
المتابعات انه لا توجد فروقات في
مدن الولايه الثلاث اذا لم تبدا خلقات
حاليا نعم ربما استمعنا الى اصوات لنيران
بهذه الصور المباشره من الخرطوم مع انه
هذه الهدنه يعني دخلت
واصبحت ساريه ولكن تسمع طلقات نيران
متفرقه
نعم وبالتاكيد في حاله في في حاله خرق هذه
الهدنه فبالتالي لا يمكن البناء عليها بان
باستمرارها
وبقبول الطرفين
[موسيقى]
اليهود اخرى او حتى لفتح الممرات الامنه
التي يطالب بها الاطباء يطالب بها
صليبه الاحمر
لاجلاء لفتح طرق ولي حتى لتغيير بعض
الاطباء يعني لماذا يعني يقبل طرفين نزاع
بالهدنه ان كان سيخرقانها
بالتاكيد الطرفان
يقبلان بالهدنه
ارضاء المجتمع الدولي ولا الضغوط الخارجيه
وللضغوط التي تمارس عليهم وخاصه من الامم
المتحده والمجلس ومن المجتمع الخارجي كل
طرف من الاطراف يريد ان يظهر بانه ملتزم
بالقانون الدولي الانساني وهو يخرج
البيانات البيانات البيان والبيان المضاد
وبالتالي في حال عدم قب
ول احد الطرفين بالهدنه ربما يتخوف من فرض
العقوبات الدوليه التي يمكن ان تفرض من
خلال اما استمرار هذه الحرب التي امتدت
اليوم اليوم الرابع عن التوالي فبالتالي
هم يعلنون القبول بالهدنه ولكن التنفيذ
يتم قرطه خلال ساعات كما حدث اليوم
هل يعول على هدنه ليس فيها عقوبات او
مراقبه دوليه على الطرف الذي يخرق
اولا المراقبه حاليا تكون صعبه جدا
في
الخرطوم في في ظل استمرار هذا هذا لهذه
النيران المتبادله المراقبه
يمكن ان تكون في مناطق او في
اماكن لا يمكن رغبته لكن من الذي الامم
المتحده تستطيع ان
تراقب ام هنالك جهاز وطنيه يمكن ان تراقب
فالمراقبه في حد ذاتها صعبه وصعب من يقوم
بمتابعتها وبراقبتها مراق
به ماذا لو طال امد هذا الصراع ماذا لو لم
يتوقف طرفي النزاع عن الاشتباكات
وحتى يعني تجاهل هذه الاستجابه النداءات
العالميه
بالتاكيد في حال استمرار هذه هذه المعارك
وهذه الحشود التي تاتي الى الخرطوم
واستمرار المعهد واستمرارها بالتاكيد في
ستكون الخرطوم
منطقه منطقه حرب الان كثير جدا من الاسر
وكثير جدا من الخدمات الاساسيه متوقفه
كثير جدا من الاسر والاوضاع الاقتصاديه
ليها صعبه جدا في الحصول على مقومات
الحياه
الموجوده الان حتى في الاسواق ربما يوصل
تنفذ المواد المعروضه للسوق الان في مشاكل
فيه حتى في شراء الكهرباء في توصيل المياه
في الوصول الى المستشفيات في توفير الدواء
في التنقل ما بين الاسره هنالك عدد من
الوفيات لمدنيين في ولايه
الخرطومه في مناطق متفرقه
الوفياء هذه الوفيات يمكن ان تجيد هنالك
حسب الشهود عيان بان هنالك جثث ملقاه على
العراء
ستكون هنالك وضع
كارثه بيئيه وكارثه انسانيه وربما كل من
يستطيع الخروج من من ولايه الخرطوم لهذه
الظروف ولهذه الاسباب يمكن ان يغادر
الطرفين يمكن ان يصل الى مرحله ان
تن
صت
الزخائيل بطرفهم لان الارهاق سيصيب هذه
المجموعات التي ظلت على استعداد لفتره
طويله جدا وحتى اللحظه هي في مرحله انهاء
وبالتالي
الاستمرار هذه المعارك فيدمر
الخرطوم نهائيا وربما تنتقل المعارك الى
مناطق اخرى
نعم شكرا جزيلا لك سيد وليد على ارائك اذا
المحلل والصحه في وليد احمد النور حدثنا
من الخرطوم ونحن مشاهدينا نستمع الى هذه
الطلقات
وربما قاذفات يعني من العاصمه الخرطوم
وكان الجيش السوداني وايضا قوات الدعم
السريع
اعلنت موافقتهما على هدنه جديده لمده 24
ساعه بدات السادسه مساء بتوقيت المحلي
للسودان يوم الاربعاء طبعا في ظل دعوه
دوليه لوقف اطلاق النار وايضا الحوار
وضع انساني يتفاقم بتفاقم الازمه التي
يشهدها السودان والاسوا هو صعوبه تلبيه
الخدمه الانسانيه والصحيه الاساسيه في خضم
الصراع الدموي الذي تشهده البلاد والذي
ادى بحياتي 185 شخصا واصابه 1800 وفق
الامم المتحده اما نقابه اطباء السودان
فقد اعلنت عن 174 حاله وفاه واكثر من 1200
اصابه حصيله اعتبارها السكان في الخرطوم
اقل من اعداد الضحايا على ارض الواقع
حصار لايام حرم الاهالي في الخرطوم وما
حولها من معظم الخدمات الاساسيه ما يصعب
تقديم العون على منظمات الاغاثه بحسب
الاتحاد الدولي لجمعيات الصليب الاحمر
والهلال الاحمر والذي اكد على وجود
الامكانات لكن انعدام الممرات الانسانيه
هو ما عرقل الوضع
الحصار تجاوز البر الى الجو ليكون اغلاق
مطار السودان وجميع الاجواء السودانيه حجر
عثره اخرى في وجه المساعدات بحسب صحيفه
الكارديان
ازمه طالت القطاع الصحي ايضا لتكون
المشافي في مرمى النيران فقد اغلقت 39 من
اصل 59 مشفى في الخرطوم ومحيطها الابواب
امام الجرحى والمرضى بسبب تضرر البنيه
التحتيه الصحيه وفق النقابه اطباء السودان
حديقه الوضع الانساني وضع كارثه
والنظام الصحي الان يمكن علينا ان نقول
انه منار تماما في ظل تعرض عدد من
المستشفيات للقصف والمباشر وخروجها عن
الخدمه
ادانتها منظمه الصحه العالميه مسميه اياها
انتهاكا خطيرا معلنه مقتل ثلاثه على الاقل
من العاملين في المجال الصحي بالاضافه
لتوقف عشرات المشافي عن العمل
الهجمات على مرافق الرعايه الصحيه انتهاك
صارخ للقانون الدولي والحق في الصحه ويجب
وقفها على الفور اطباء بلا حدود التي
انشات مشما في دارفور خلال 48 ساعه
استقبلت ما يقارب 136 جريحا توفي منهم 11
شخصا متاثرين بجراحهم
كما ابدت المنظمات قلقها من نقص المعدات
الطبيه الذي قد يودي بحياه المزيد وما زاد
من عبئ مهامها اعتراض المقاتلين في
الخرطوم لسيارات الاسعاف التي تنقل الجرحى
او حتى الجثث اذا عمر العربيه
وينضم الينا من مدينه مراووي مراسل عربيه
نزار بقداوي اهلا بك نزار يعني تسمع في
الخرطوم اصوات اشتباكات متقطعه بين الحين
والاخر ماذا عن مروي
مروي هذه الان هدوء نسبي بعد ان سيطر
الجيش السوداني القوات المسلحه على مطار
وقاعده مروي الدوليه بعد خمسه ايام من
القتال والاشتباك واستخدام للطيران الحربي
واستخدام للمدفعيه الثقيله ان جرى الموقف
الامني والعسكري الان وهي مرحله قد وللت
خلال الساعات الماضيه لكن الان الترتيبات
تمضي وفق المصادر العسكريه وفق قيادات
عسكريه هنا
لتعزيز هذا الوجود في المطار ولتعزيز وجود
القوات المسلحه السودانيه في كل المناطق
التي كانت ترتمر تتمركز فيها قوات الدعم
السريع بالانتشار جنوبا نحو مدينه ام
درمان في حدود محليه مروي في الناحيه
الجنوبيه الان مروي هادئه تماما لا وجود
لقوات الدعم السريع لا نستمع الى الطلقات
نار لا نستمع ذوي مدفعيه حتى تتعامل مع
مجموعات كانت موجوده ولكن حسب ما راينا
اليوم وحسب ما شاهدنا وحسب دخول القناه
واصول الفريق القنالي مطار مروي والقاعده
تاكد لنا تماما انه بات الان في سيطره
الجيش السوداني القوات المسلحه ولا وجود
لعناصر الدعم السريع الان الحاله هادئه
تماما المدينه تمضي فيها الحياه بسلاسه
الكره الان
يراقبه وينظر
ويحاول ان يطمئن اكثر وهو يتابع مع الات
هذه العمليه العسكريه المتفاعله في
الخرطوم نزار هل هنالك من نقاط اخرى غير
المطار كانت تتمركز فيها قوات الدعم
السريع ولا تزال في قبضتها
قوات الدعم السريع عندما غادرت قاعده مروي
الجويه والمطار نذكر بان القاعده هي ملحقه
بمطار مروي الدولي عندما غادرت يوم الامس
اتجهت جنوبا جغرافيه المنطقه مروي تقع في
شمال السودان جنوبا من هذه المحليه وهذه
المدينه الطريق البري الذي يربط بين مدينه
ام درمان التي تنضم الى العاصمه الخرطوم
ومباشره الى مدينه مروي عندما خرجت قوات
الدعم السريع اتجهت جنوبا صوب الشريط
القروي في اتجاه الجنوب صوب مدينه ام
درمان وتعاملت معها قوات الجو السوداني
عبر طلعات جويه اكدت ايضا المصادر بان عدد
من السيارات التابعه لقوات الدعم السريع
تضررت ضررا بليغا واكد شهود عيان بان
عشرات السيارات التابعه للدعم السريع التف
فيها السبل في عدد من الاوديه والطرق
الفرعيه خلافا للطريق الرئيس المواطنون
وشهود العيان في مناطق نائيه من محليه
مروي يذكرون ويؤكدون بان عدد من القوات
الدعم الفريق كانت تتمركز خلال يوم امس في
عدد من النقاط في عدد من القرى لكنهم غير
موجودين الان في تلك المناطق يبدو انهم
اثروا ان يغادروا محليه مروي لا نعلم هل
هو التمركز هل هو تموضع في منطقه اخرى
ولكن المؤكد حسب الجيش ان قوات الدعم
السريعه الان خارج حدود المطار وخارج حدود
هذه المحليه كنت افتن برساله سابقه بانه
النازحين من مدينه مروي يعودون اليها
تدريجيا بعد سيطره الجيش بطبيعه الحال على
يعني المطار الذي هو اهم نقطه بالمدينه
نعم عرض المواطنون او جزء كبير منهم اثر
ان يعود مره اخرى بعد ان غادر مضطرا منزله
ومسكنه الان حاله الهدوء وحاله التمركز
للجيش داخل مدينه مروي وداخل نقاط تفتيشيه
حتى تبعث مزيد من الطمانينه والامن دفعت
كثير من المواطنين ان يعودوا لمنازلهم
ويطمئنوا على اهلهم وذويهم الذين غادروهم
امس وامس الاول الطرقات سالكه داخل
المدينه خدمات الكهرباء متوفره
المستشفى يعمل المرافق الحكوميه لم تعمل
اليوم لكن لاحظنا حراكا اقتصاديا ولو بدا
قليلا داخل سوق مدينه مروي نتوقع يوم الغد
ايضا
ان تمضي وتيره الحياه الى نسق مرتفع مع
اقتراب عيد الفطر المبارك والمواطنون في
هذه المنطقه بطبيعه الحال يحاولون ان
يجهزوا المستلزمات اللازمه لعيد الفطر
المبارك وهم يتمنون ان تمضي الساعات
المقبله بعيده عن كل اجواء التوتر التي
تعيشها عدد من مدن السوداء
لا اعلم ان سمحت لك الفرصه بزياره مطار
مروي بعد عودته للسيطره الجيش او من
معلومات متوفره حول مدى تضرره
وتضرر المناطق المحيطه به
نحن كنا ظهر هذا اليوم داخل مطار مروي
والقناه كان لها صور حصريه من داخل المطار
رصدنا حجم الضرر الذي اصاب بعض الطائرات
ورصدنا ايضا حجم الضرر الذي لحق ببرج
المراقبه الرئيس ورصدنا ايضا الاضرار التي
لاحقت بسيارتين
يتبعان للدفاع المدني الذي يقدم الخدمات
اللوجستيه لاطفاء الحرائق وتامين المنطقه
لاحظنا ايضا ورصدنا عبر الصور الحيه
من المرافق الاداريه ومكاتب مدير المطار
ومكاتب امن المطار تعرضت للضرر البليغ
ايضا المدرجه الرئيس الذي يمتد على نحو 4
كيلومترات ايضا تضرر بعض الشيء اداره
المطار قالت انها تضع الان لحصر الضرر
وربط التقرير ونحن نستمع الى اصوات
الاشتباكات المتقطعه بالعاصمه الخرطوم كنا
افدنا بانها بمحيط القياده العسكريه
بالعاصمه طبعا هذه الهدنه التي يعني كان
هناك يعني تبادل بين طرفين نزاع الاتهامات
بخرق الهدنه الاولى والتي كما نشاهد بانها
خلقت مره اخرى ولو بشكل متقطع
طبعا هناك دعوات دوليه واقليميه لوقف
اطلاق النار بين البلدين
انا اسمعك نزار تفضل
نعم كنا قد اشرنا فيما اشرنا سابقا الى ما
الذي حدث داخل مطار مروي الدولي المطار
تضرر بنسب مختلفه الان التجري او تجري
اداره المطار عمليه حصر للاضرار حتى ترفع
في تقرير شامل يوضح نسبه الضرر وما الذي
يحتاجه المطار وما المدى الزمني اللازم
حتى يعود المطار الى سابق عهدي اللي يقدم
خدماته اللوجستيه وخدمات الملاحه الجويه
في هذه المنطقه المهمه من السودان
اما عن الحديث حول الضرر الجانبي الذي لحق
به ممتلكات المواطنين لم يكن بالضرر الذي
رصد بنسبه كبيره عدا بعض المرافق الخاصه
بمواطنين سواء محل تجاريه او غيرها او
مستودعات لكن تظل العمل
المقاطعه ولكن ستكون بطبيعه الحال مع
الزميله ميسون بهذه التغطيه
المستمره لهذا النزاع المسلح في السودان
فتابعوها الى اللقاء
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات